the movie begins with a family of three
who has been living inside a nuclear
bunker for 301 days the parents ray and
claire have always emphasized two key
rules to their daughter zoe to always
remain calm and never leave the shelter
sadly the world above them has been
deserted due to a strange viral outbreak
and now they are the only survivors left
although it has been 301 days since the
infection began the ground is still
extremely dangerous as the epidemic has
given birth to dangerous creatures known
as the breathers who kill any humans on
site
the scene shifts to 301 days ago when it
first began the family of three is
living in a peaceful neighborhood when
suddenly they notice their neighbors
start frantically packing to leave town
when asked what happened the neighbors
do not answer but swiftly drive away
instead it turns out that a highly
contagious viral epidemic has hit their
small town named kingsville scared of
getting infected the inhabitants leave
their homes and drive down the highway
to escape however they are stopped
midway by the cdc who declare the area
to be under quarantine as the people
step out of their cars a pair of fighter
jets drops multiple bombs nearby
attacking the scared citizens as they
run away in fear amidst the chaos ray
leads the family to a nearby elementary
school just as the fighter jets drop
another bomb nearby they find a hatch
leading to the shelter and enter it back
in the present zoe wakes up one night
after having a nightmare about the
breathers infiltrating their shelter the
mother quickly calms her down assuring
that she is safe as her dad ray is out
keeping watch to ease her concerns
claire takes zoey to meet rey who is
just returning from his watch shift rey
further assures her that she's safe and
allows her to climb a ladder leading to
the shelter's exit when zoe reaches the
top she discovers that the opening is
firmly locked with an array of secure
chains seeing this a paranoid zoe is
finally convinced and returns to her
parents as the family heads for the
shelter's pantry in there zoe alongside
claire conducts their morning ritual of
carving a line on the wall to signify a
new day after doing this zoe counts the
wall's markings and realizes that they
have spent a total of 301 days alone in
the shelter this realization saddens zoe
as she has no friends her age and is
tired of staying in the gloomy shelter a
few minutes later zoe sits to have
breakfast while claire scans the pantry
shelf for food however they soon
discover that the container is empty on
investigating claire finds that a rat
had entered the pantry and eaten through
most of the canned foods thus shortening
their already limited options the family
also discovers that the rat managed to
sneak into the shelter through an
opening other than the main barricaded
hatch they find a small air duct but ray
reassures zoe that the breathers
wouldn't be able to fit through that
duct left with very few alternatives and
no remaining peach cans the family
settles for a plate of beans for
breakfast he disappointed zoe sulks over
the beans and picks at her meal as she
refrains from eating weary due to their
situation zoe rants about the subpar
living conditions and complains about
being cooped up in the shelter rey
understands her and consoles his
distraught daughter as he explains the
importance of staying in the shelter to
hide from the breathers eventually zoe
sees reason and resumes eating after rey
cracks a joke to brighten the mood later
that night claire joins zoey in the
other room the duo plays monopoly but
zoey soon becomes disinterested and
bored of the game seeing this claire
hands zoe a periscope to view the ground
above if games are boring you little one
how about a peek at our inevitable
demise looking through the device zoe
sees the outside world but is
disappointed to find nothing but a
wasteland after the brief viewing zoe
returns to play monopoly with claire at
the dinner table while playing zoe spots
the rat munching on one of the cans and
silently alerts her mom eventually she
also calls a sleeping ray to the pantry
as the trio decides on how to kill the
beast after a long deliberation claire
kills the rat before it escapes but in
the process the rodent knocks over one
of the lamps which explodes causing an
overwhelming fire claire instantly
brings a cloth and tries to put out the
flames while rey heads for the pump to
get water once again the faulty pump
malfunctions causing ray to struggle
with the lever while claire screams at
him for help fortunately ray gets it to
work in time and together the duo puts
out the intense flames when the fire has
been fully quenched the family discovers
that the residual smoke has entered the
air vents and is escaping to the ground
above seeing this the family figures
that the breathers could see the ash on
the overhead ground and decides to head
to the surface to cover their tracks
after instructing zoe not to leave the
shelter the couple heads for the surface
to get rid of the residual ash while the
couple clears the ground zoe watches
them through the periscope right then
she sees a strange figure
lurking behind her parents and assumes
that it is a breather zoe screams to get
her parents attention further drawing
attention to them but the couple who are
a long distance away don't hear her
disregarding their instructions zoe
opens the hatch and exits the shelter as
she races to her parents to warn them of
the lurking creature outside zoe finds
no one and screams their names as she
wanders around searching for them
suddenly claire pops up behind zoe and
shuts her mouth to stop her incessant
screams when claire releases zoe the
little girl warns the couple of the
strange figure she saw behind them the
shapes that zoe saw turn out to be a
herd of deer
but the trio realizes that they must be
running away from something and so they
immediately sprint to the open hatch and
head for the shelter just as they enter
the underground facility the family
hears the loud footsteps of a breather
plodding along the ground overhead to
avoid being discovered they all remain
mute as they nervously listen to the
footsteps above just as they begin to
fade zoe's doll starts bugging out
making a ruckus after her pull string
accidentally gets caught on a nearby
pipe horrified by the doll sounds ray
swiftly grabs the toy and destroys it
just in case zoe needed a little more
trauma in her life to prevent it from
attracting the creature however it is
too late as the breather has heard the
doll and violently attacks the hatch to
access the underground shelter
one by one the chains are pulled from
their moorings and seeing this rand
claire climbed the ladder to wedge the
door shut for one terrifying moment it
is opened and skarsgard goes full
barbarian on the creature outside
afterwards they get the wedge in place
stopping the creature from breaking in
on hearing no further sounds clare and
ray climb down the ladder and reunite
with zoe as they all heave a sigh of
relief however this is short-lived as
the sounds on the roof intensify thus
revealing that more of the creatures
have arrived the family tries to get
another wedge for the hatch but before
they can react the breathers destroy it
as the heavy metal falls to the ground
seeing this the trio sprints to another
room in a desperate attempt to escape to
buy some time claire hauls a lamp at the
passageway causing another fire after
which she and ray use a shelf to further
obstruct the way after this they search
for an alternate exit and decide to use
the vent that the rat used previously
with rey's help claire passes through
the tight opening and emerges outside
reaching the overhead ground claire
scans the area and fortunately spots no
breathers claire quickly informs rey who
then also helps zoe through the vents
once mother and daughter have made it
through rey tries to climb as well but
can't seem to fit in a desperate moment
raid dislocates his shoulder and tries
to fit in however before he can make it
outside the breathers make it through
and attack the injured man pulling him
back into the shelter on looking down
claire and zoe are horrified to see a
splatter of blood and eventually assume
that rey is dead after taking a moment
to grieve him making an absolutely
idiotic amount of noise the duo sprints
through the dark roads and emerges on a
highway filled with a lineup of empty
cars right then a helicopter with a
bright headlight appears in the sky
seeing the chopper the duo runs in the
opposite direction however they don't
make it far before they're captured by a
fired net as they struggle to free
themselves from the net the breathers
appear from the shadows and surround the
door as they step into the light we
learned that the breathers are in fact
not monstrous creatures at all but
actually american soldiers wearing full
protective face masks in a flashback
scene 301 days ago we see claire into
the family right after the aerial attack
in the bunker claire finds a cut on her
hand and shows the rest of her family as
it turns black signifying that she is
infected seeing this the family realizes
that the virus is airborne and has now
infected the entire town back in the
present the armed men ask the duo to
calm down as they whip out a syringe to
test them for the virus as the soldiers
extract their blood they discover that
the pair are indeed infected learning
this the army men surround them with
guns and prepare to fire however before
they pull the trigger
rey who is transformed into a
vampire-like creature with black veins
and bloodshot eyes attacks the soldiers
exhibiting superhuman strength he
manages to kill a handful of them but
ultimately gets taken down by the others
who riddle him with bullets here we get
a shocking revelation of the true nature
of the virus the family are actually the
infected ones while the breathers are
just normal people um so how did they
yank the hatch so hard that the chains
broke the virus though contagious is not
lethal as the infected can live an
almost normal life so long as they do
not lose control then we discover why
rey and claire insisted on the rule to
always stay calm at the start of the
movie apparently the infected can lose
control of their emotions and become
monsters however if they stay calm they
remain like normal humans sadly this
does not rule out the fact that they are
infected and therefore dangerous and the
army wants to kill them all when the
soldiers are done with rey they look
back at the net only to discover that
claire and zoe have escaped a few
moments later zoe hides in a car while
claire transforms into the same
vampire-like state and easily knocks out
three of the four remaining soldiers
however she is shot and injured by the
last surviving soldier just as the armed
man is about to take the final shot a
transformed zoe jumps at him and removes
his face mask exposing him to the virus
zoe tries killing the soldier but is
ultimately stopped by claire don't give
him a quick death dear let him live a
cursed existence too eventually the duo
leaves the man and walks down the
highway as they search for rey a few
meters away the duo finds a dying ray
lying on the floor and tearfully say
their final goodbyes shortly after
claire and zoe spot another chopper
approaching so they run into an
underground tunnel hidden under a pile
of destroyed wood as the pair heads
inside the tunnel they run into joey the
son of their next-door neighbors who
they last saw a year ago at the start of
the outbreak miles and miles away from
here the little boy leads them to a
hatch and on opening it reveals a sewer
system below inside claire and zoey
discovered that there are other infected
survivors who have been living in the
kingsville sewers for months seeing this
mother and daughter are relieved to have
finally found other people like them
zoey climbs down the hatch to join the
welcoming group with claire following
shortly after the movie ends as claire
stares into the sun with bloodshot eyes
before ultimately shutting the hatch
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching